[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
laurie est celle de galles nouveau look
la chaîne bien c'est la seule alors oui
sportswear racé lalaurie non mais j'aime
bien franchement j'aime beaucoup mon co
et faillit très simple il y a quelque
chose derrière
derrière ce rideau regarder très
discrètement tous les deux et on va
devoir dire ce qu'on voit tu peut
bluffer
mouais à où tu peux dire la vérité et
dans ce cas là il y aura un bluffeur est
quelqu'un qui dira la vérité vous avez
vos petites pancartes qui dit la vérité
civile de cauet je vais d'abord regarder
c'est qu'il y avait à oui d'accord qu'un
second d'accord oui et oui d'accord il
faut qu'il faut qu'il faut que tu
d'accord allez au niveau qu il va
regarder il va nous dire ce qu'ils
voient à we are well as bon alors est ce
que tu peux pas dire ce que tu as vu
comme moi je vous le dira à l'intérieur
ouais je décris ce que j'ai vu
exactement après tu peux mentir
elle accepte de jouer le jeu derrière il
ya evangeline habillés maquillés en in
time en cuir et vangelis et mabillon une
stat boiziot je vais vous dire ce que je
vois tu viens de regarder mais il revoit
pas ce qu'il y'a pas de mal et donc moi
je vous dis derrière dans la cabine ya
geneviève de fontenay en train de jouer
du biniou suis dit la vérité la vérité
et ça vous pensez quoi que j'aime bien
de poteaux en train de jouer du biniou
et vendredi l'église en achetant des
titres chez moi
[Applaudissements]
je vous le montant droit du but voilà
c'est ça qui joue de bisous à suspense
[Applaudissements]
regarde regarde ce qu'il ya du loup dit
vas-y attention il ya une deuxième yade
et m 2e km au bluff ou vue il va nous
dire ce qu'ils voient et coco alors
d'accord je vais regarder monsieur c'est
quoi à n'importe quoi jean prix là dans
la cabine
vas-y ya là vous le dis il ya une poule
de luxe
oh c'est pas moi c'est pas ben rhodes
les poules une poule de luxe ou de luxe
tout simplement
ouais ou à l'intérieur doit être cabine
il y a quelqu'un vous connaissez
roselyne bachelot habillée en cerise de
groupama
elle te vends des ltte vendée assure
aussi un problème ils t'envoient raymond
du service sinistre mais là c'est ce
raid sur moi je vous dis y'a et on n'a
pas été aussi loyal il ya juste une
poule même poule de luxe à dire une
poule avec des bijoux dit la vérité aux
docks et ne rendent penser qu est à fond
gilles verdez mais qu elle est donc
c'est moi on est d'accord mais vous
croyez qu et aux majorités non sire il
peut te vas tu regardes la marque et
couilles
non moi je dirais oui mais toi non tu ne
peut plus changer c'est fait c'est fait
john merrick toi tu sait mentir
oui on s'est regroupé à dire attention
lui bondi en couille
merci roselyne c'est cool non je prends
[Applaudissements]
la poule 6 le regarde
regardez et elle a de l'usiné l'inde est
prête à la bbc le pool est et d'où elle
est belle ma jolie va de la chercher
pour qu'elle n'ait pas pu faire des
achats c'est pourquoi n'ai pas peur car
attention ma chérie d'après la poule que
voilà bien faible des sports pour les
croisiens de cabine quelques coups les
trois hommes cabine est nourrie tient de
la joue avec wade a joué avec cauet y
aller et laurie contre correa l'aura
faire l'oreille contre caux et on
installe alors là là là n'ont pas tout
de suite avec la lorie vient d'un chien
et loup rien dire est qu'elle un défilé
de mode magnifique alors loris tu vas
essayer de bluffer d'accord ou ou bien
tu as tu vas dire ce que tu vois et
mettez vous d'accord mettez vous
d'accord
de deux on verra celui ci attend je
prends note d'accor tout comme ça
d'accord vous allez voir troisième
cabine à bloc je sais ce qu'ils envoient
des rien regarder tous les gens qui
arrivent à ce moment là c'est bizarre ça
alors alors qu ils vont s'est pas mis
d'accord
ouais ben aguida cru qu'elle est black
blanc vert alors je vous explique le
principe il y a quelque chose quelqu'un
dans cette cabine qui va bluffer qui dit
la vérité qu etc et s'ouvrir aux femmes
honneur aux femmes dans la maison qu'est
ce que vous avez c'était horrible
c'était quoi tu vu
mike tyson mike tyson dans la cabine
comment enstream mike tyson en fonction
soit possible quand même
[Rires]
moi j'ai vu celle qu'on avait envie de
claquer quand on était gamins à la télé
nellie oleson dans la petite maison dans
la prairie
mais en modèle qu'elle tombe pas dans la
colline allez debout elle est en jeu
avec la truck de l'époque
après quoi il faut que ce soit crédible
au sénat l'y attend il n'y a pas le père
qui dit dubois
ouais y'a pas la petite qui tombe tout
le temps mais en mode lan il est en
pleine promo pour le film attention
qu'ils avaient pensé à ce détail
voilà je vais juste vous demander qui
dit laurie et jean michel maire
apparemment il vous faut donc y en a qu
audi mike tyson on est bon on va
regarder tout de suite je regardais kia
il ya des lieux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]